[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Ted bellick with reason TV thanks
for joining me today I'll be speaking
with clay Epstein VP of Sales and
acquisitions for the little film company
you may know the little film company
from such films as an American haunting
and Tsotsi a redemptive tale about a
South African street thug which won the
Academy Award for Best Foreign Language
Film in 2005
clay thanks for joining us my pleasure
Ted thanks for having me so talk to me
about the little film company and what
you do for a living my job primarily is
I kind of break it down into three
responsibilities one is to find movies
for us to produce executive produce and
then the marketing of the film and then
the distributing or selling of the film
and selling not necessarily to the
consumer but to businesses around the
world that will then distribute the film
which means put it in the theatres put
it out on video and put it onto
television what's it like selling films
to China it's it's interesting you have
a different set of challenges when you
sell a film to China every film that's
released in China has to go through a
censorship approval they have a
censorship board they have one that's
four films that are going to be released
theatrically and they have a different
one for DVD and for television can you
explain China's attitude towards
releasing films that have
anti-government themes I haven't seen
any written guidelines of the censorship
board in China but from what I
understand and for what films you see
being released and accepted
it's ones that do not talk about
anti-government or that are about
speaking out against government and it
doesn't matter who the government is
right it's right and ghost stories the
ghosts coming back to haunt the kids
that type of story is not going to be
allowed something like the others they
wouldn't yeah the others I I don't know
for sure if it was released in China or
not but I would think it probably wasn't
and those films that are made in China
are usually made with the censorship
they usually send a representative from
the censorship division or censorship
board to visit the set read they they
read the script before it's made visit
the set they work with the filmmakers
people think censorship that China is
probably one of the first nations they
think of are there any other nations or
territories that come to mind yeah I
mean a lot of this
a lot of the Southeast Asian countries
have censored Malaysia has censorship
Indonesia has censorship
India has censorship what kinds of
things won't get through each countries
a little bit different I mean Malaysia
is a Muslim country so that that in and
of itself is gonna probably have certain
they're sensitive boards looking for
certain things Thailand has a censorship
board and it and it changes a lot I mean
sometimes I'll get a call from
distributors saying well we used to be
able to show people smoking in a film
and then they come you know they could
they call you and say listen you have
that film and you know the protagonist
he's smoking away in the movie and you
know the Thai government has now passed
a law that we can't show that openly in
films because we don't want to promote
smoking to young kids so it's everywhere
censorship is everywhere but that was
one that happened in Thailand a year or
two ago and I don't know if that ban has
been lifted or not but you couldn't show
smoking openly you can show someone I
think holding a cigarette but not taking
the hit and blowing the smoke out and
they were they were that's the
difference between corruption this yeah
if you're just holding it maybe you're
not maybe right but this this is this
you're blowing the smoke out you're
getting the car you know you're getting
the toxins that that that movement is
afoot here in the states as well yes but
it's it's there's a movement but it's
not the government saying you can't
release the movie of someone smoking to
what extent or movie goers tastes
Universal versus culturally specific
like when you come across a script you
ever say oh this would this would kill
in Korea or the Germans are really going
to love this that's how we have to read
a script to see where their value of it
is there was a big rise in horror films
the past few years just completely
saturated with horror films because they
work everywhere culturally you don't
have to explain to someone who doesn't
speak English and did not grow up in
America that if someone's chasing with
an axe it's scary and you have to get
the hell out of the way that's not
that's there's no cultural understanding
there you know what exactly what's going
on in that film so the opposite side of
that is probably comedy
we're Borat may not have been as
successful in Japan because the Japanese
just may not get a lot of that humor may
not get the jokes then you have
something like Bollywood in India well
they've got you know a huge indigenous
industry right there is there are there
any other kind of movers and shakers
that we're gonna see in the next few
years Korea there was a movie called the
host which was phenomenal and it the
effects were great and the story was
very hollywood-esque it was all Korean
and it was released here and it didn't
do huge numbers but it was one of the
first ones and the past few years
Korea's film industry has boomed it's
really really grown very fast and it
actually it's direct competition you
know the the company a client will say
to me I can't buy your film because I
have you know I'm already releasing 15
Korean movies that I'm really gonna make
money on in Korea and three big studio
films from the US where do I put your
independent film I can't make enough
money on your independent film because
the audience wants Korean movies are big
Hollywood studio films you see the
emergence of Eastern Europe even as sure
as a hot shirt people go into Romania to
make films Lithuania yeah well there
they're going they're going and
everyplace you mentioned it's a little
bit different scenario going on I mean
studios people from all over the world
are going to Lithuania Romania to make
movies because it's cheaper bottom line
they're gonna go where it's cheaper to
make a film in terms of choices
everything that's out there is this a
good time to be a film but I think it is
a good time to be a film buff but look
you have you have movies from Korea now
to choose from and from China and from
more movies from Hong Kong and all over
the world that countries that were
making films before because films are
cheaper to make on the independent side
for instance if you you know someone
could just go buy a four thousand dollar
camera make a film so I think it's a
very good time to be a film under
accessibility you have access to films
from all over the world and you can
check out reason TV and exactly play
I've seen everyone thanks for stopping
by
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]